bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver en
direct sur figaro live à ce mercredi 9
juin 2021
une date qui marque la réouverture des
cafés et des restaurants en intérieur
les terrasses je vous le rappelle ont
rouvert depuis le 19 mai dernier les
restaurants sans terrasses vont pouvoir
ouvrir et enfin accueillir leurs clients
pour témoigner de cet événement tant
attendu on peut le dire nous avons le
plaisir d'être en direct ce matin avec
un chef étoilé qui s'apprête à rouvrir
son établissement à bordeaux bonjour
philippe etchebest
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en direct
ce matin sur le figaro figaro live pour
cette journée particulière c'est la
grande ouverture des portes de votre
brasserie le quatrième mur aujourd'hui
on imagine que vous êtes un homme
heureux ce matin
oui je suis heureux mais équipe aussi on
attend ce moment depuis des mois on voit
je l'espère le 8 mai elle mais je peux
m'empêcher de rester prudent malgré tout
il faut il faut être très rigoureux dans
la mise en place des protocoles
sanitaires pour accueillir nos clients
en toute sécurité et nos collaborateurs
bien sûr donc voilà faire attention à
l'effet enthousiasme de tout ça et
surtout faire attention pour que ça
puisse durer je l'espère aussi
comment vous vous êtes préparés à cette
réouverture concrètement est-ce que
c'était dans dans la sérénité ou avec
malgré tout de l'appréhension voire
peut-être de l'inquiétude
alors il ya toujours la petite boule au
ventre avant le match voir le combat
c'est normal c'est une bonne pression
maintenant c'est vrai que cette pré
ouverture elle est un peu différente de
la première puisque j'avais mis en place
la vente à emporter qui permettait de
d'avoir cette cohésion avec les équipes
et surtout cette activité cette
dynamique qui va nous permettre de
rentrer lancer dans de meilleures
conditions
par rapport aux premiers déconfinement
qui a été plus compliqué puisqu'on avait
complètement arrêté et c'est très
bizarre mais en même temps ça s'explique
c'est comme les sportifs de haut niveau
quand ils s'arrêtent de s'entraîner et
sont moins performants et ça a été le
cas
nous lors du premier des confinement
pour l'instant là le gouvernement a fixé
une et georges à 50% vous ne pouvez
remplir votre votre bras strict qu'à la
moitié de sa capacité
vous n'avez pas ouvert votre terrasse en
mai dernier pour des raisons de coût est
ce que cette fois ci ce 9 juin vous
pouvez ouvrir sans trop de casse on va
dire alors j'ai pas ouvert la terrasse
pour des raisons de coût certes mais
aussi pour des raisons de météo
j'ai une terrasse qui est très mal
exposés elle est protégée sous un
péristyle ou si je suis dans l'enceinte
du grand théâtre
il ya beaucoup de courant d'air il fait
très froid en fait ma terrasse elle est
bien quand il fait 30 degrés à
l'extérieur
donc il ya aussi cette raison là qui
fait qu'il ya des paramètres qui
rentrent en ligne de compte et qui était
extrêmement compliqué pour moi à gérer
aujourd'hui le temps est là ma terrasse
va être pouvoir va pouvoir être
exploitées et j'ai toujours la
possibilité de servir l'intérieur si si
j'avais des problèmes maintenant la
jauge de 50% à l'extérieur mais c'est un
peu ce qu'on avait eu lors du premier
des confinement donc on va s'adapter
mais en tout cas je suis déjà très
heureux de pouvoir et réouvrir avec la
terrasse à 100% et l'intérieur aussi
donc ça va le faire pour les internautes
qui nous regarde en ce moment sur figaro
live et sur youtube vous n'hésitez pas à
poser vos questions à au chef philippe
etchebest qui est en direct avec nous ce
matin jusqu'à 10h30 sur figaro sur
figaro live et sur youtube vous avez
certainement des questions des
commentaires à lui faire parvenir je
suis là pour les relayer philippe
etchebest on vous a souvent entendu vous
figure très populaire désormais pendant
cette crise tapé du poing sur la table
si je puis dire pour faire entendre les
inquiétudes voire la détresse des
restaurateurs qu'est-ce qui a été le
plus dur à vivre pour vous ces derniers
mois d'un point de vue professionnel
évidemment et que peut-être plus
personnel ce qui était dur à vivre
professionnellement c'est dans les
lettres dans cette attente est de ne pas
savoir si c'était surtout ça qui était
compliqué de ne pas avoir de perspective
vous savez quand vous êtes vraiment dans
cette attente la cc c'est dur à gérer
je sais pas si vous aimez imaginez quand
même ne pas ne pas travailler depuis
plus de 9 mois maintenant c'est moi j'ai
pas l'habitude de ça je travaille depuis
l'âge de 14 ans pratiquement écrit que
c'était quand même assez douloureux même
si cette activité de vente à emporter
bon il y avait une entreprise qui font
ça ne fonctionnait pas normalement vous
pensez que d'autres décisions étaient
possibles on vous a entendu reprocher en
particulier les les premiers mois au
gouvernement les décisions qui étaient
prises de fermeture de confinement le
fait d'empêcher finalement les
restaurateurs de travail et vous pensez
qu aujourd'hui avec le recul même si les
cours encore que d'autres d'autres choix
aurait pu être fait oui le recul est en
cours encore très très court maintenant
pour faire le match et pas un problème
c'est facile de refaire le match mais
c'est vrai que il ya quelques mois c'est
vrai que j'avais un peu critiqué le fait
qu'on n'est pas finalement pris des
décisions un peu plus un peu plus ferme
pour pouvoir rouvrir plus tôt mais je
vous le dis c'est facile de refaire le
match
bon maintenant c'est fait il faut faire
avec et aller de l'avant et regarder
regarder devant vous aimez un filer la
métaphore la métaphore 10 sport les
métaphores sportives on reconnaît là le
combat tant que vous êtes vous rouvrez
d'ailleurs c'est que vous êtes encore là
encore sur le ring que vous avez la
capacité de le faire comment vous avez
maintenu votre votre entreprise à flot
malgré les difficultés financières vous
avez raison de faire la comparaison avec
le sportif que j'ai été que je suis
toujours d'ailleurs c'est le mental est
extrêmement important la faculté
d'adaptation l'est aussi bien sûr donc
j'ai fait preuve de résilience comme
beaucoup d'autres et c'est de trouver
des solutions pour pouvoir maintenir
justement une certaine activité puis à
sortir la tête de l'eau
on a eu l'aide de l'état et on peut s'en
féliciter
et se dire que on a la chance d'être en
france aussi c'est vrai que j'ai râlé
souvent mais il a fallu se battre aussi
pour avoir ces aides c'est pas l'oublier
moi comme d'autres l'ont fait et
aujourd'hui
de toute façon faut savoir que c'est
elle ne peut pas perdurer non plus parce
qu'on ne peut pas vivre que dead
il va falloir retrouver une activité
normale j'espère qu'il arrivera très
rapidement mais ça va être encore dur
pour certains malgré tout effectivement
les aides dont les restaurateurs ont pu
bénéficier jusqu'à présent pendant cette
crise sanitaire vont progressivement
diminuer est ce que ça vous inquiète
wissam inquiète d'autant plus qu'il va
falloir rembourser les prêts garantis
par l'état les exonérations vont
s'arrêter et forcément il va falloir un
seuil de rentabilité plus importants que
la normale puisque le prêt garanti par
l'état n'est pas prévu dans le plan dans
le plan de fonctionnement
ça veut dire qu'il va falloir travailler
plus rentrer plus d'argent pourquoi
rembourser ses prêts et je ne pense pas
que tout le monde ait la capacité de le
faire
d'autant plus qu'on se retrouve
aujourd'hui confronté à un problème
c'est la main d'oeuvre on a beaucoup
entendu parler mais moi j'ai beaucoup de
confrères qui n'arrivent pas à trouver
le personnel nécessaire pour pouvoir
assurer une ouverture totale et que
paradoxalement mais ils vont devoir
limiter leurs activités
donc faire moins de chiffre d'affaires
et de notre côté il va falloir
rembourser puisse vous voyez c'est ça
reste compliqué quand même ça reste
compliqué et vous avez dit chez nos
confrères du jdd le week-end dernier que
je vous cite si les aides sarrès nos
entreprises ne sont pas viables
est ce que votre enfant votre entreprise
avouent le quatrième mur votre brasserie
à bordeaux pourrait faire faillite dans
les prochains mois si la clientèle n'est
pas au rendez vous si vous avez des
difficultés de recrutement si les aides
financières de l'état ne sont plus là
mais quand vous annoncez tout ça je vous
dis oui tout de suite
si j'ai pas de clients je pourrais
fermer la porte c'est sûr aujourd'hui on
voit qu'il ya un réel engouement que le
carnet de réservations se remplit plutôt
bien donc je suis assez optimiste
maintenant il va falloir que ça dure
aussi un c'est vrai qu'il ya cette fort
il a qui arrivent qui est très spontané
qui est très très forte
mais voilà il faut que ça dure toute
l'année c'est trop fort et on a parlé au
début de la crise financière de la crise
sanitaire pardon et vous même vous étiez
le premier à le dénoncer que des
des entreprises des restaurateurs des
cafetiers allait faire faillite que 40 %
d'entre eux ne survivrait pas
aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore eu un
panorama suffisant on va dire pour
savoir quelle est la situation
effectivement financière globale de
votre profession est-ce que vous avez
d'ores et déjà vous connaissance de
confrères qui ont d'ores et déjà fait
faillite ou qui sont sur le point de
faire faillite malgré les aides alors il
y en a certains effectivement qui sont
sur le point de fermer il y en a eu
pendant le confinement maintenant on
peut pas mesurer vraiment les faits
l'effet de cette fermeture puisque on a
bénéficié dead qui nous ont permis
justement de maintenir nos entreprises à
flot là où on va voir et si côté un peu
pervers de la chose c'est après en fait
quand les aides nous serons tenus là
comme je voulais dit alors il va falloir
tout remboursé c'est là où ça va être
plus compliqué donc forcément et j'ai
envie de vous dire j'espère me tromper
mais malheureusement il y aura y aura de
la casse malheureusement il y aura de la
casse est ce que comme le disent
certains ça permettra pas de faire une
sorte de nettoyage de la profession
alors de toute façon tous les ans il ya
des entreprises qui ferment des
restaurants qui ferment
d'accord c'est un espèce de cycle qui
qui arrive
il ya des restaurants qui ferment ils
sont repris par d'autres et oui ça
tourne comme ça constamment donc on
arrive je crois à peu près globalement à
entre 20 et 30% de faillite mais qui
sont systématiquement reprise c'est vrai
et je crois qu'il faudrait profiter de
cette crise pour je pense réguler
davantage la profession
moi je le vois dans les émissions là
j'ai affaire à des gens qui ne sont pas
du tout du métier et qui font un peu
tout et n'importe quoi
vous savez un poids lourd et un salon de
coiffure il faut avoir un diplôme il
faut avoir plusieurs années d'expérience
avant de pouvoir espérer ouvrir son
propre cabinet et je pense qu'il serait
bien de le faire aussi pour notre métier
voilà avoir cette expérience là les
brevets pour pouvoir assumer l'ouverture
d'un établissement restaurant parce que
ça ne se fait pas comme ça en fait bien
avant la crise philippe etchebest votre
profession souffrait on va dire d'une
mauvaise image sur le plan du
recrutement de du secteur ça donnait pas
vraiment envie
jeunes parce qu'on parle de turn over de
salaires extrêmement bas du difficulté
un des horaires de travail
est ce que il ne faudrait pas selon vous
profiter de cette crise pour redorer on
va dire l'image de cette profession et
redonner envie aux plus jeunes de
s'engager dans cette voie là à mes
disques serment c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement important et je crois qu'il
ya 130 mille collaborateurs qui ont
changé de voie pendant ce confinement
est aujourd'hui à plus de plus de cent
mille postes à pourvoir
donc c'est ce que je vous disais
auparavant ça va être très compliqué
pour certains mais je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les jeunes ne souhaitent
plus sacrifié leur vie personnelle pour
leur vie professionnelle sans des
avantages qu'ils ne trouvent peut-être
pas ou plus c'est vrai qu'on travaille
le soir on travaille le week end on
travaille quand les autres samut mais
c'est ça fait partie de notre métier
aussi c'est pour sa vocation c'est une
passion aussi alors je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous sur le fait qu'il
faut valoriser je pense
les collaborateurs à travers le les
salaires je suis le premier à le dire
mais pour ça effectivement il faudrait
baisser les charges patronales c'est
important faut savoir que nous avons la
masse salariale et craie donnez-nous
effectivement alors du concret quelle
est cette cale que représente en
pourcentage cette masse c'est ces taxes
de l'état sur sur un salaire d'un
salarié chez vous
la masse salariale on paie deux fois le
salaire en fait deux fois on le paye
hockey et la masse salariale dans nos
dans nos entreprises dans notre métier
dans notre profession est excessivement
élevés c'est la plus élevée en fait la
plus élevée de tous les métiers parce
que nous sommes un métier de service et
qu'il faut du monde pour ça d'accord si
on devrait appliquer les tarifs pour
avoir mais pour mieux payé peut-être nos
collaborateurs et avoir suffisamment de
monde pour créer le turn over pour
éviter peut-être les coupures tout ça
franchement aujourd'hui il faudrait il
faudrait vraiment baisser les charges
considérablement
aujourd'hui je vais parler de mon cas
mais je ne veux pas faire que ça non moi
je peux me permettre de le faire d'avoir
trois équipes dans mon établissement
parce que j'ai un volume suffisant pour
le faire
ce qui permet de donner des conditions
de travail très confortable mais
maintenant tout le monde ne peut pas le
faire on a un service à gérer l'humain
un service à gérer le sont
donc c'est des coupures forcément c'est
des amplitudes horaires et malgré ça il
faut les respecter
les collaborateurs que ce soit dans dans
la restauration dans notre métier ils
ont 8 9 heures à faire par jour et pas
plus voilà parfois que tu existes
mais c'est toujours rattrapé de toute
façon donc il faut vraiment aujourd'hui
donné un confort de travail à nos
collaborateurs est aussi un salaire mais
ça passe par justement des baisses de
charges pour pouvoir répercuter cela sur
les salaires de nos salariés et moi je
suis vraiment le le premier à le dire il
faut vraiment le faire parce que c'est
bien ce sera une période qu'on pourrait
donner aux jeunes pour les inciter à
revenir dans notre profession donc il
faut vraiment rêvé à ça alors ça veut
pas dire que je paye mes jeux que je
paye mal mais les collaborateurs bien de
fraude car je pense que je les paye bien
mais aussi un confort de vie qui est
important vous parlez de carottes à
donner aux jeunes de leur donner envie
d'une revalorisation salariale si je
vous demande à combien vous recrutez vos
salariés en tout cas en bas de l'échelle
si vous engagez demain un jeune cuisiner
chez vous combien sera-t-il payé en
salaire brut
alors inconnu a commis c'est la base il
touche alors le salaire brut soit
salaire brut mais oubliez pas prompt
père bon je sais qu'on est amis on à
1400 euros n'est donc cette brute ou
1900 brut
acura combien selon vous la le flux est
un peut être un peu saccadée pour
l'instant sur le réseau le pardon on
n'est pas bien là je vous ai pas entendu
je vous demande juste de reprendre votre
dernière phrase à d'accord je disais que
quand on arrive dans le métier bien
évidemment on arriva à la base donc le
comice donc on touche le smic mais il ya
des possibilités d'évolution dans mon
restaurant c'est ce que je fais je fais
évoluer les collaborateurs au fil du
temps et en fonction de leur progression
vous parlez de 2400 euros nets
à combien faudrait-il majoré ce montant
net pour qu'il devienne intéressant
selon vous et puis je crois que vous
pouvez donner mais ce serait mais je
pense que comme ça là où je pense qu'ils
en arrivent à donner 100 euros net par
mois en plus hauts collaborateurs c'est
ça vachement vous j'aimerais tellement
qu'on sorte grandie de cette période de
dingue c'est encore une réflexion que
vous avez donnée à nos confrères du jdd
vous y croyez oui vous savez la
profession mais également les français
l'ont du fer résilience et dans toutes
les preuves il faut en savoir tirer
parti et faire ressortir le positif
la vente à emporter a permis de
mobiliser les équipes et conserver le
lien avec les clients donc adapter nos
modes fonctionnement est vraiment pour
ça moi je félicite mon équipe et je
remercie tous ceux qui nous ont soutenus
il ya des choses qu'il faut en tout cas
moi que j'ai fait que je n'aurais jamais
pensé faire je vais me servir de ça
justement pour continuer à le faire
voyez je pense que si ce n'était pas
arrivé je n'aurais pas pensé donc il
faut se servir de ça et comme je voulais
vite sortir du positif de cette crise
pour pour avancer pour faire progresser
notre métier à propos de deux périodes
de dingue je ne peux pas ne pas vous
faire réagir à ce qui s'est passé hier
lors d'un déplacement du chef de l'état
emmanuel macron en province
un spectateur on va dire qu'elle est un
badaud qui étaient présents dans la
foule a giflé le président de la
république
quelle réaction cela a suscité chez vous
c'est lamentable 6010 c'est complètement
débile
franchement c j'ai du mal à le commenter
en tout cas c'est si on fait du mal à le
commenter parce que ça veut dire que
pour vous ce symbole dépasse simplement
le geste
oui il ya somme on décompte déjà giflé
quelqu'un ça ne se fait pas de le faire
au moins respecter ce à quoi mais je
suis moi infligé par au delà de la
violence
j'entends parler de violence bon c'est
une gifle d'accord moi ce qui me fait
peur aujourd'hui c'est la violence qui
peuvent subir nos jeunes quand je vois
des jeunes qui se tape à coups de
marteau ça ça me tirait à bon port vous
trouvez qu aujourd'hui on est dans une
période beaucoup plus violente qu'elle
ne l'a été il ya encore quelques
dizaines d'années que je n'apprécie
l'aggraver j'ai l'impression
j'ai l'impression il faut vite faire
quelque chose souvent il ya certains
individus qui qui vous aiment qui vous
qui vous qui vous idole qui vous
idolâtre pardon qui aimerait que vous
vous engager en politique de voir des
images comme celles ci savourer froide
ou au contraire ça pourrait pousser à un
engagement chez vous au delà de 2 des
interventions télé et dans le domaine
public un engagement si je ne sais pas
le palais jusque là franchement je suis
cuisinier je suis un cuisinier engagé
certes avec avec des idées avec avec des
valeurs aussi qui sont extrêmement
importantes salles et je côtoie je
côtoie beaucoup de chance énorme de gens
de tous les deux tous les milieux et de
tous les niveaux et c'est vrai que je
m'aperçois même dans des milieux assez
faibles où il ya plus de repères je
rencontre des jeunes qui en fait
peut-être le respecte beaucoup parce que
j'ai je renvoie je renvoie des valeurs
mais des valeurs positives aussi des
valeurs de respect
les jeunes comme tous ont besoin d'un
cadre et de repères et aujourd'hui j'ai
le sentiment qu'ils n'ont pu ses repères
là et c'est bien malheureux parce que je
pense qu'ils sont demandeurs c'est pas
on n'a pas affaire à des comment
dirais-je je crois j'ai l'impression
qu'on a affaire à des gens qui sont un
peu perdus en fait ils ne savent pas
quoi se raccrocher
je ne sais pas si je peux apporter
quelque chose dans ce sens là mais
peut-être qu'à premièrement discours ou
à travers ce que ce que je montre dans
mes émissions mais même au quotidien
dans mon établissement mais si ça peut
apporter quelque chose et j'en serai
très fier
vous savez je reçois même dans le
restaurant je voulais revenir alors par
rapport aux jeunes qui vient dans la
profession on est aussi un peu le métier
de la dernière chance reçois des gens
qui n'ont pas de formation qui n'ont
plus rien et que nous formons et ça
c'est extrêmement important parce qu'il
se rapproche à quelque chose qui peut
les sauver aussi il ya eu une relation
en fait par rapport à ce que je lui dis
que qui est important on a l'impression
dans vos hésitations dans ce raid télé
dans cette réflexion que vous avez
concernant ces jeunes parfois en
perdition que vous aimeriez aider ou
remettre un petit peu dans dans le droit
chemin pour parler de façon un peu
caricaturale
peut-être que cette idée a l'air de
cheminée dans votre esprit et que vous
êtes peut-être en train d'y réfléchir
pour apporter peut-être des solutions
qui dépasse un peu vos engagements
d'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je suis en
train de réfléchir à une manière comment
bon je peux vous dire que nous allons
parler parce que j'écris quelque chose
qui est en train de mûrir dans ma tête
avec mon épouse on a parlé qu'avec des
gens je connais très bien qu'ils sont
dans le monde de l'agriculture justement
cherché cherché à faire quelque chose je
peux pas vous en parler parce que c'est
pas c'est pas abouti encore mais mais
j'ai réfléchi très sérieusement vous
êtes perçu 1 philippe etchebest et on
l'entend on le voit on vous connaît
maintenant depuis de nombreuses années
vous êtes perçu par le public comme
quelqu'un de profit de profondément
humain et bienveillant et vous avez
champ vous avez changé et vous continuez
de changer le parcours de la vie de
femmes et d'hommes que vous accompagnez
que vous
et en particulier à travers les
émissions qu'on connaît est-ce que c'est
parfois un fardeau trop lourd d'avoir
cette responsabilité de porter les
individus vers vers le meilleur ça
pourrait l'être effectivement mais je la
supporte cette charge est cette fois sur
sa lutte et après très franchement je ne
calcule pas c'est peut-être ma force je
réfléchis pas je t'aime plus page je
suis moi même quand ça me plaît je le
dis quand ça me plaît pas je le dis
aussi que ça plaise ou non
j'assume mes propos à chaque fois et je
pense je suis en tout cas naturel et
sincère à chaque fois et c'est peut-être
pour ça que c'est à dire aussi voilà je
le calcul oreilles mais j'assume tout
est-ce que ça est ce que ça vous touche
quand on vous dit que vous êtes humains
bienveillant quelqu'un qui qui fait du
bien
forcément ça me touche
évidemment ça me touche ça me rend fier
et ça prouve finalement que c'est pas
compliqué je suis pas je suis pas
meilleur ou moins bon qu'un autre c'est
juste d'avoir du bon sens et puis j'ai
été élevé avec des valeurs et avec des
règles puis j'essaie de retransmettre
aujourd'hui avec une éducation si je
vous assure j'ai pas l'impression que ce
soit compliqué parce qu'on ne force pas
et parfois je peux faire des choses bien
parfois je peux faire des erreurs aussi
et je les reconnais ces erreurs là je
vois là je suis con dit j'assume tout et
malgré tout on se demande comment
comment se protège de cette image de
sauveur entre guillemets en faisant
beaucoup de choses et je fais beaucoup
de choses vous savez j'aime la cuisine
énormément je suis à fond dans mon
restaurant qu'on 18 mai quand j'en sors
je pense à autre chose
j'aidais mon activité sportive j'ai fini
sport depuis l'âge de 7 ans 8 ans et je
continue à faire du sport ça me permet
de me vider la tête et l'esprit je fais
la musique aujourd'hui beaucoup avec mes
potes
donc dès que je peux je répète et que je
peux essayer de faire des concerts on va
voir cet été
quelques-uns je suis aussi avec ma
famille heureusement un petit peu voyez
jeu j'aime partir en moto quand je peux
en fait c'est sain
un emploi du temps qui est extrêmement
chargé sept jours sur sept
tous les jours mais j'arrive à rentrer
tout ça dans ce planning et ça me fait
des différences et des tribulations qui
permettent à chaque fois elle être
performant ou en tout cas meilleur quand
je reviens à une case voilà je travaille
par case je sécurise ses skis c'est ce
qui me sauve peut-être aussi
j'arrive vite à oublier et à passer à
autre chose
très organisés également vous imagine
volontiers comme quelqu'un de
perfectionniste
est ce qu'il vous arrive parfois de ne
pas faire les choses à fond et et de
baisser la garde
c'est pas bon de baisser la garde
les coups qu'on risque que le chaos il
faut être toujours vigilant et je crois
que alors vous disiez très justement
finalement je suis obligé de l'avoir
toujours très haut de gamme et être
toujours vigilant parce que parce que je
suis très regardée et plus qu'avant donc
ça me demandent à faire peut-être plus
d'efforts mais mais c'est pas c'est pas
dans la douleur une fois de plus ça
m'oblige à aller toujours de l'avant et
c'est très bien et ça me correspond ça
correspond à mon état d'esprit mon côté
compétition où justement rien et à qui
il faut jamais rester sur sur ce qu'il
sait faire l'immobilisme et dangereux
très dangereux et pour avancer justement
il faut sortir toujours de sa zone de
confort
et finalement cette situation me permets
m'oblige à sortir de ces zones de
confort et ça me va très bien
ça vous a très bien et ça me fait penser
que régulièrement on vous voit souvent
avec la montre d'un personnage très
connu et qui est aussi est un personnage
mythique devenu mythique en tout cas et
qu'ils n'avaient pas qu'ils n'étaient
pas statique et qu'il ya des poteaux la
bougeotte on vous voit souvent avec la
montre de steve mcqueen au poignet un
point commun que vous avez avec ce
personnage mythique qu'est ce que vous
aimiez chez cet acteur mais c'était un
c'est un type qui allez quoi qu'ils font
c'est qu'ils avaient aimé kébé les
sensations fortes
j'aime les sensations mes sensations
fortes aussi donc je me retrouve un
petit présent ce personnage là la
vitesse à la vitesse alors toujours la
moto bien sûr mais toujours toujours
maîtrisé attention ne pas ne pas non
plus respecté le code de la route mais
c'est vrai que sur circuit
j'aime bien j'aime bien avoir des
sensations fortes puisque le faire ça me
plaît énormément
on arrive à la fin que cet entretien
philippe etchebest je sais que vous
devez partir ailleurs en tout cas vous
avez d'autres impératifs on on n'imagine
surtout en cette journée de du 9 juin
qui marque la réouverture des
restaurants
merci beaucoup de nous avoir accordé cet
entretien et merci aux internautes
d'avoir suivi ce direct
je rappelle donc vous rouvrez les portes
de votre restaurant le quatrième mur
aujourd'hui à bordeaux on vous souhaite
évidemment le meilleur du monde pour
cette renaissance on va dire
et puis on n'oublie pas aussi un conte
vous retrouve ce soir sur m6 pour la
finale de top chef
rendez vous dès 21h 6 poursuivre cette
cette 12e édition il a feint d de 18
semaines de compétition entre 15 jeunes
cuisiniers ce soir y en a plus que deux
qu'un ce sont sarah et mohamed est ce
qu'on suit les consignes de m6 philippe
etchebest qui recommande de ne pas
suivre
à 21h05 le programme de top chef mais
plutôt d'aller au restaurant et puis de
regarder le replay après tu t'achètes
accord avec m6 effectivement aller au
restaurant et regarder tf1 replay
important aujourd'hui la réouverture des
restaurants et la m6 a eu raison de de
passer ce message là et je les suis
complètement
merci encore un grand merci à vous
philippe etchebest pour cette demi heure
passée ensemble passé ensemble sur sur
figaro l'avait sur youtube en direct ce
matin bon vent et à bientôt
merci beaucoup
merci a bientot on voit au revoir vous
nous rejoignez en ce moment en direct
sur figaro live nous sommes ici pour
commenter cette réouverture aujourd'hui
9 juin des restaurants en intérieur
puisque jusqu'à présent ce sont les
terrasses qui ont pu rouvrir en pouvant
les remplir sous certaines conditions
les restaurants aujourd'hui rouvre dans
paris en province avec une jauge à 50 %
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne posent pas
dépasser la moitié de leurs capacités
d'accueil
eh bien on souhaite comme à philippe
etchebest qui est chez basse qui qu'ils
le puissent avoir du monde aujourd'hui
nous serons dans quelques minutes ou
maintenant en direct avec thibault il
aurait qui doit nous faire partager
l'émotion d'une gérante de restaurant
dans paris il est normalement en direct
avec nous devrait la voir dans quelques
secondes
j'entends le son de la rue parisienne
qui vont ils auraient vous êtes
effectivement devant halamish au bois un
restaurant situé dans le 12ème
arrondissement de paris ce restaurant
n'a pas de terrasse où on avait une
petite terrasse en tout cas ce n'était
pas sa spécialité la connexion dans mon
oreillette
y aller dans ces conditions parce que
morte en décharge
oui absolument vous entends thibault je
disais donc pouvoir commencer
excusez-moi de cette interruption
oui cher devant tant d oui et je disais
que c'était un grand jour pour sa
gérante et et son personnel à la biche
au bois situé dans le 12ème
arrondissement vous allez vous faire
vivre ça exactement exactement charlotte
donc bien bonjour à tous merci de me
retrouver aujourd'hui sur figaro live on
se retrouve ici au
aux 45 de l'avenue rue gouraud là dans
les deux
ainsi vous voyez
cet établissement à droite qui disposent
de terrasses assez importante ça ce
n'est pas une nouveauté c'est le cas
depuis le 19 mai et bien cet
établissement sis qui se nommait bien à
la biche aux voix lui est bien ne peut
ouvrir qu'aujourd'hui on se suit juin
puisque bien il ne disposait pas des
installations nécessaires pour pouvoir
bénéficier d'installations en extérieur
et ainsi accueillir ses clients
on va donc faire partir à la rencontre
de sa gérance et vous allez le voir il
vient aujourd'hui toute l'équipe de ce
restaurant s'affairent pour aimer bien
préparer l'arrivée de la clientèle qui
on peut l'attendre nombreuses revenir à
partir d'aujourd'hui
alors bonjour céline merci de nous
accueillir ici à la guiche voix
j'imagine que pour vous c'est une grosse
journée alors à quelle heure commence
votre service midi et j'imagine que
contrairement à une journée
traditionnelle
il ya peut-être une émotion un peu
particulière alors il ya à la fois du
stress et à la fois de l'émotion elle a
fait vingt ans que je suis là et j'ai
l'impression de l'attak mon premier
service d'entrée ce temps
on à la fois content de voir de la vigne
et des gens paniquent et massingy bri
comment se sont passées ces huit mois
d'interruption très dur très long très
dur et va moralement ça que c'est un peu
mon papier surtout sur la fin quand tout
le monde était un peu ouvert c'était
assez compliqué par compliqué et
moralement financièrement il était temps
pour nous surtout et puis même pour les
un peu complexe
on y reviendra en tout cas est ce que
vous pourriez m'expliquer un petit peu
quelles sont les tâches à cette heure-ci
quelques quelques dizaines de minutes on
va dire de l'ouverture du restaurant
s'est déjà essayé d'organiser notre
terrasse parce que comme c'est des
terrasses nouvelle donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident de trouver comment
faire
la livraison des marchandises qui a pas
du tout à l'heure prévue normalement
délivrés à 7h30 pas tout le nettoyage
dans tout ça a été fait mais c'est
vraiment les derniers préparatifs
sa terrasse recevoir la marchandise
préparer tout l'occident est une coque
vide donc du coup c'est vrai que là on
est un peu mais ça y est je pense qu'on
va on va être pas trop mal je suis
présent donnera le ton des jeunes et nos
amis 10 mai au mans sera prêt pour pour
ouvrir aux clients les attendait
beaucoup de clients d'ailleurs oui bah
non on a tous les habitués dont un trail
à 80% de l'habitude et donc c'est vrai
qu'ils attendent tous avec impatience
donc on
on va dire une moitié des salles de
réserver en ligne et sans doute par les
habitants c'est vrai que ça s'est un peu
enfin pas de renoir
quand il m'a appelé pour tromper
c'est vrai qu'on se trouve parfaitement
entre la gare de lyon et la place de la
bastille un peu un esprit de quartier
c'est fort dans dans le quartier
ce point du 12e tour on se connaît tous
passent devant le restaurant la pub
semaine
avec des mots d'enfant alors la grande
nouveauté de cette journée c'est donc
bien l'ouverture des salles toutefois 50
% de capacité
est ce que pourrai me décrire la vôtre
mais expliquer un peu comment vous avez
organisé les plans de tables d'accord
alors là vous en rendez pas trop près
selon l' espace et l'état mais
normalement chez nous c'est vraiment
l'ambiance bistrot un peu bouchon
lyonnais donc vous avez l'étape très
serré par exemple si vous a mis deux
petites tables de deux normalement j'ai
2 tab 2 4 donc on a un peu espacées
lourdes on va la préparer j'ai mis deux
tables de deux si vous voulez aux jets
d'eau remettre 3 et après sur l'étape
plus grande à vélo mettre ses couverts
on en met 4
et puis en fait ce qu'on perd dedans
pour l'instant on a la chance de
récupérer à l'extérieur l'instant il
fait bon récupère son manque de dents
alors on peut peut-être revenir sur
votre menu je crois savoir justement
qu'une de vos spécialités cesser les
gibiers donc un produit de saison si on
veut le manger frais ça vous rajoute
pour vous finalement j'imagine à votre
savoir faire une contrainte
supplémentaire ce ces questions
sanitaires et surtout c'est ça une
grande interruption
alors le gibier particulier des cuissons
préparation c'est moi mais mes cuisines
et arrive à 7h30 le matin pour
contrairement à 9h30 10h ailleurs donc
faire beaucoup de normes d'hygiène on
doit les stocker a passé décrit son long
il faut les idées les plus mais aimée
par contre ça amène aussi une valeur
ajoutée au restaurant sert de septembre
à mars on a vraiment une clientèle qui
vient que pour ça alors on les fait en
plus du reste c'est c'est vraiment ce
qu'est ce qu'on fait à part ça va partir
mais ça amène une grosse grosse
clientèle et 5 pour nous mais assure
jean s'est passé fin de saison donc on
va attendre septembre pour pouvoir
est ce que vous pourriez nous faire
découvrir l'intérieur les coulisses j'ai
envie de dire de votre établissement
j'imagine que plus que d'habitude
il ya beaucoup plus de choses à faire ça
doit être un petit peu le chérèque on a
un peu tout côté on dire non mais sans
les frais après ça le fera après sauf
qu'on est après et que la riba et en
plus y'a un journaliste qui vient vous
embêter pour savoir où le salut à la
cuisine
bonjour à tous walid aux plongeurs ce
qui me seconde cuisine et la belle anna
ils sont à fond à fond dans la
préparation du casse pattes chevaux
les cuissons et c'est pareil je les
voyais un peu à peu tendu donc je me dis
que c'est pareil ils sont repérés sont
tous là je suis très longtemps mais là
je les sens un peu plus tendue que
d'habitude surtout le chef qu'elle
méritait reconcentrer
voilà voilà notre cuisine la forte houle
a pas trop comment ça se passe justement
pour pour vos employés j'imagine que si
on jugeait cette période d'interruption
avec beaucoup de conséquences oui oui
bah oui oui ça a été compliqué parce que
surtout que j'aurai les salaires ils
sont pas 80 % à 25 % de leur ca niveau
de l'activité c'est des gens qui bossent
14 heures par jour et c'est vrai que je
suis homo bi à protéger te retrouver
comme ça
cinq aspects financiers tu parlais pour
boire son sang de reprendre cette chance
dans le monde est revenue chez nous non
plus on a cette chance là on voit votre
personnel de cuisine si on compte aussi
le personnel de service vous disposez de
combien d'emplois alors on a tourné aux
personnes avec l'ue midi et du soir
donc là on a fait
venez trois quarts des personnes puis on
va voir un peu comment ça va être
compliqué mais pour dépenser bond lié au
compte plus les touristes n'ont pas 13
ans top
c'est pas si on peut rester comment vous
l'appréhendez set fut tout à l'heure en
été avec le chef philippe etchebest qui
nous expliquait que la suite resté
encore pleine de suspense et aussi de
l'intérieur d'appréhension la suite
parce que c'est vrai que ces derniers
temps même le gouvernement mais c'est
vrai que là si l'activité repart fait un
jouet de caraman le gouvernement il est
possible d'arrêter ces aides c'est là le
deuxième facteur c'est entre bastille et
république su et donc les manifestations
et mouvements sociaux etc savent pas
s'ils viennent ne désemplit sport avec
la période les concepts ans ça va
repartir de 5 alors que j'étais pas ce
qu'est le seul représentant on va dire
parle pour nous un peu
judicieuse et c'est vrai que ce qu'ils
vivent l'entendent et aussi celle en
boîte de la presse ont tous phares
éteints hypothèse est que le chômage
partiel d'actif moi je vois l'année
dernière quand on a rouvert à cette
période on a fait 10 % les chiffres donc
sert exception lèvres paris 04 suivait
haute commissaire excitant lève le
chômage partiel la ménagère montrer
comme ça que ça ne presse surtout par
exemple chez nous les gars sont là c'est
dix ans pour les derniers instants pour
les est en tout cas on l'espère pour
vous peut-être la réouverture prochaine
on le sait dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines des frontières
européennes de frontier le français
surtout aux ressortissants européens
peut-être pourra vous apporter des
touristes au sein de votre clientèle de
l'autre côté moi j'avais pu vivre en
direct dans une autre cuisine parisienne
l'ouverture des restaurants du premier
déconfinement que nous avions connu à
l'époque ces gérants avait expliqué être
un petit peu sans filet et sans aucun
encadrement de la part du gouvernement
et des autorités sanitaires
comment ça se passe pour votre journée
de réouverture à vous ce que vous avez
eu des indications des explications
vraiment aller les chercher
c'est à dire que c'est à toi un peu
d'aller chercher sur le net sur un peu
perdu
on nous demande alors on entend les
grandes lignes comme vous à la télé en
fait le monde mais on n'a rien de plus
la personne qui t'ont voix ou qui te dis
allez sur tel c'est donc vraiment aller
chercher des protocoles l'ouverture même
qu'on trouve et on nous demande
d'imposer des prospectus avec les règles
sanitaires a effectué un stage tu
pourrais aller chercher un peu partout
et on fait tous un peu à vue en donnant
des renseignements les uns avec les
autres mais ça que c'est pas hyper clair
on a parlé de l'avenir pour vous et ses
appréhensions
qu'en est il de votre présent et aussi
de la perdre qu'eux voulaient connaître
comment si je puis me permettre
se déroulent vos finances et chalon pour
vous répondre honnêtement c'est assez
catastrophique parce que c'est vrai que
depuis on va dire qu'il ya un an
louis
1500 euros dans la boîte en toute
logique que pendant six mois donc le
perde pas raison dans notre cas 35000
euros en moi les héros revenus pour nous
c'est là que nous jette en consultant
les deux mois de zéro depuis fin mars
c'est vrai que ça va on s'est débrouillé
on a eu des jets ma famille sympathique
qui nous avons fait un peu aidés
maintenant c'est vrai que
j'en incorporation de travail comme des
fous on n'a personne
et du coup c'est vrai qu'on trouve qu'on
l'a été quand même un peu
fondée à des gens soit dit vraiment son
salaire qui peut y arriver et prendre un
salaire sur la boîte même avec les mains
du gouvernement s'est pas passé donc
c'est vrai qu'on s'est senti quand même
abandonné à titre personnel par exemple
paris tng ranch cotisent au chômage
je n'ai pas le droit en temps normal
mais ces règles dans une blague comme ça
j'en ai eu à minimum un minimum au moins
au rsa aura quelque chose
sap a été fait après là on a fait avec
les tendres alors justement pour revenir
sur une note positive
qu'est ce que vous proposez aujourd'hui
de bons à manger alors nous mais en
dehors des gibiers on travaille beaucoup
les volailles donc par exemple
aujourd'hui on a un magret de canard au
miel gingembre
g d'amandes on n'a pas touché après on
travaille aussi les boss côte de boeuf
doute pour deux côtes de veau donc ça
c'est pour les plats qui apprendra
quelques salades un salad de ravioles
faucher salade de pétoncles à
l'escabèche non-valeur dehors des
gibiers on travaille et volaille
toujours le coq au vin qui n'ont pas de
là les gens mangent même mois d'août la
fin on va écouter j'espère que ça
donnera peut-être envie à de nouveaux
clients de s'ajouter à votre clientèle
d'habitués comme vous même expliqué et
je vous souhaite en tout cas un bon
courage pour la suite de cette période
on le sait si compliqué pour les
restaurateurs
eh bien merci beaucoup céline je vous
souhaite une bonne chance pour votre
journée de réouverture j'espère que tout
se passera bien alors que les fraises
arrive bon genre essieux
merci merci beaucoup de joie mais voilà
je vais bien clôturer ce live devant la
façade de ce restaurant à la biche au
bois je le rappelle aux 45 de l'avenue
ledru rollin dans le 12e arrondissement
juste entre la gare de lyon est celle de
la bastille et donc eh bien je vous
souhaite à tous une très bonne journée
en cette journée de l'ouverture du 8
juin pour une partie des restaurants je
vous rappelle un que la grosse
information de la journée c'est bien
justement cette extension des mesures de
déconfinement avec d'un côté et bien
l'ouverture des terrasses à 100% comme
on peut le voir chez le voisin de cet
établissement mais également et surtout
l'ouverture des salles à 50% puis et
bien une série d'autres d'autres mesures
de déconfinement que vous pourrez
retrouver tout de suite sur la page
principale du figaro au dessus de ce
live je vous souhaite à tous une très
bonne journée
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis et à
bientôt sur figaro live
merci beaucoup thibault iso est notre
envoyé spécial pour le figaro dans le
12e arrondissement de paris vous avez pu
entendre le témoignage de céline gérante
de à la biche au bois ce restaurant qui
rouvre aujourd'hui à l'extérieur
évidemment puisque c'est une petite
terrasse mais surtout son restaurant en
salle à l'intérieur puisque ce 9 juin
2021 baisser la réouverture enfin des
restaurants en intérieur et des cafés
vous avez pu entendre son témoignage et
puis son émotion sa joie de rouvrir au
jour d'aujourd'hui donc pour ceux qui
veulent aller déjeuner dans paris
rendez-vous à la biche au bois en
terrasse ou à l'intérieur de ce
restaurant tenu par par céline et et ses
équipes
merci encore de nous avoir suivis en
direct depuis 10h ce matin où nous
avions la chance d'avoir en direct le
chef étoilé philippe etchebest depuis
bordeaux qui a répondu à un certain
nombre de questions et qui nous a fait
le plaisir de nous parler de lui aussi
personnellement vous pouvez retrouver le
replay de cette émission sur figaro live
et sur youtube dead et l'interruption et
dès la fin de ce direct à 13h sur figaro
live ce n'est pas fini puisque vous avez
rendez vous rendez vous avec bruno dray
pour tout savoir sur le pass sanitaire
mis en place dès aujourd'hui les experts
du figaro chloé boîtier journaliste tech
au figaro ainsi que vincent bordenave
journalise santé répondront à toutes vos
questions en direct cet après midi dès
13 heures et ce jusqu'à 14 heures au
moins
et moi je vous dis à très vite sur
figaro live merci encore